how's it going citizens of the reject
Nation we are back once again to take on
ten Masters that's right it's time for
Ip Man Two I am very excited and thank
you guys for just being so gracious and
for responding so well to the first Ip
Man I cannot wait to continue the series
and with me in the hot seat is Roxy
stryer how you doing Roxy yeah I'm so
glad that they liked the first one
because I was really nervous we were
never gonna be able to watch the second
one and I've been like anxiously waiting
for this oh sure well and with Donnie
and tearing it up in John Wick chapter
four now is the perfect time so guys why
don't you go ahead and leave a like on
this video go ahead and subscribe to the
channel subscribe to roxystryer as well
as the World Girls how the world girls
doing they're whirling baby oh yeah
whirling and twirling gonna repeat the
joke from the first intro it got better
the second time so much better he's
swirling the third time swirling Merlin
and uh hurling you're Sterling like
silver but we're gold but you're gold
there you go that's what I've been told
and hey if you want to get the full on I
appreciate it I feel so supportive if
you want the full on experience with us
everything that doesn't make these
reaction highlights come on over to our
patreon page patreon.com the real
rejects where you can sync up with your
own copy of Ip Man 2 and enjoy the
complete experience alongside us and uh
Hey without further Ado you ready to
throw down on some Kung Fu action is
Rock C ready to rock yeah are you ready
to see
you ready to Wing Chun yeah you know it
let's jump into this dude I feel like
there's a pun that I am missing but
we'll find it after that okay
[Music]
how many years after did this come out a
few two two 2010 we're in okay the year
is 2010 year is 2010. Roxy's in high
school and she's ready for it man too
I'm in college at this point baby ready
for it man too but apparently not
because here we are in 2023 yet again
starting with that dull color
yeah last time on Ip Man
oh buddy
whoa
like Sin City all of a sudden
oh I'm excited I've seen a couple of his
movies
it looks sketched totally in the
background that's wild yeah it's a cool
combination yeah
[Music]
score is beautiful too it's so swelling
and Epic
it's interesting too it just an action
director there's so much action it's a
whole job sure absolutely it's like
choreographer almost I guess
thank you
I'm never too good for your daily
practice
do you know what that thing's called you
know I should comment below
I feel like a dojo kind of thing yeah
it's gonna open up his official school
he's ready to really teach can you
turbina
somehow those clothes are going to
become Kung Fu the sheets I like that
she said clothes it's like 15 sheets
you know it's not about fabrics and
garments it's about martial arts okay
totally it's not laundry man
[__]
oh no
you see the inner conflict it's so not
like him to knock at the door and
confront the problems head on yeah and
especially after where they came from
the first movie and how to be in this
position
to go from like
tyrannical oppression to now just trying
to scrape by prior to that being just so
rich yeah ever poised though
foreign
I mean hello
clearly a student of principle
oh a jean jacket feels restrictive for
that I know it's a heavy cloth although
it might make good protection
showing like new school versus old
school right yeah
oh God that's just like multiple punches
or so visceral yeah they just move their
arms so fast
[Music]
jeez it's been stunned
stupefied
nobody makes me bleed my own blood
oh
knuckle sandwich
you could pay my entire rent now right
brings other people oh he's fighting
dirty all right
[Music]
smart
oh
wow
[Music]
got a point so much Style with such an
effortless Grace
[Music]
golf I see
hello God pay your fees
Donnie Yen is just so endearing and
charismatic when he smiles I like melt
in my soul I know I just wish anyone
would smile at me like that I just feel
so comforted
can I see
what if I hired 10 men with weapons to
come here to challenge us
wrong come on he's not made for this
world if you're just too good that's
always
yeah
who would read this now
oh this poor guy attention monso
yeah
oh
poor guy
oh no
it's wartime man how is it your fault
guys
or I'll whip your ass it's wild how
important respect is in this culture
sure
respect and etiquette yeah
famous last words you think he's learned
enough to win I don't know
okay maybe he has it oh
[Music]
I don't know that was not a good sign
with the hat was not a good sign
whoa
nice also he was told to run so
ah oh no oh no
oh geez
[Music]
it's not funny but he learned enough at
least for one it's been progress
now live
yes
Ransom it's like a lawless land you
can't do that it's like the Wild West in
a way just instead of like you know
gangs of Ruffians you just got different
factions of Masters of kung fu the
cigarettes the martial arts bizarre you
gotta have one Vice in this slave
but it's also the third you know like
smoking was good for you back then it's
actually 1950 here there's the title
card up at the top but still you know
smoking was good for you in the 50s
right because he has such great
endurance yeah that's how is probably he
trains with the smoke in his lungs to
make them much more capacious
oh wow
Jesus
how
many men is this
way more than 10. yeah do we get a count
yes
ah
wow
nice teamwork way more usage of props in
this one yeah
and like more cutting in general but
last time we had feathers now we've got
wood yeah wow
[Laughter]
whoa
don't get mad at me don't you want to
see him on Dancing With the Stars
yes now I didn't know I would but now I
do that
work is so great his kicks oh sure and
he's so light on his feet yes So
Graceful
no run
20 more
damn
nope oh smack him
hello what's up
oh geez no
oh hey
what he's back
let's do this
for the master oh
[__]
oh no
foreign
they're arresting him for what this guy
owns the street you know what are you
gonna do it's this word against IPS okay
so this one so far still great more out
there than the first one yeah yeah yeah
welcome have a seat
you have a little something for me
I feel represented finally
it deals this is my favorite character
three percent
you tell me
I'm not gonna talk about that now thank
you
he's in a different movie right now a
little bit as all white folks should be
our own moving
foreign
well done I love that it man accepts
anybody if they come as the best version
of themselves like he doesn't need an
apology just happy to have them be good
yeah you can see the growth yeah
come on
oh he's gonna send one of them he's
gonna trade himself for the kid right
can go
oh yeah oh geez
oh
yeah
you're making me look like an idiot from
a master hoop he's a funny character
yeah
big question
I love his growth and that I can now
actually be excited to see him yeah yeah
totally he was such a dick yeah and they
completely faked me out in the first one
idiots
y'all don't even know about it you're
gonna put some respect on that name
challenge accepted he goes by everybody
else's rules too to show respect like to
the systems man it man is just Class Act
absolutely and probably to show that he
can he's not so rigid that he can't just
adapt right he needs to
foreign
[Music]
well don't all jump up there at once a
bunch of wimps
I've seen
he keeps doing this like squint like the
whole thing
an interesting active Choice oh
how does he fly like that he's got an
interesting Vibe about it yeah really
interesting I'm kind of liking his
choices
wow
some of these shots are nuts
hey
did he punch him in the balls
they are
letting me win he tries to like save
everybody's rest dignity truly Leader by
example impeccable in his word
whoa whoa
wow nice
oh geez
I was rolling off the table
oh
yeah get up there boss man put your
money where your mouth is he's like The
Godfather we're like
Tony Soprano or something sure yeah
whoa oh my
foreign
oh man
take
come on Jimmy Olsen
[Laughter]
capture the magic
that's so cool
no no no no no no oh
okay
whoa whoa
the double
such a clever way to raise tension
this is bloody knuckles over here
the table
that's so [__] cool
sick Murphys
foreign
what's a hundred dollars a month going
to I don't trust you you're making a
shop
it's like a protection fee on your
against your own people yeah it's like
what if you've got the police and stuff
in your pocket too you're probably uh
just just paying it's like paying the
mob yeah maybe a little more respect but
generally
um
ah
well done my guy
respect him yeah no I'm here for it he
invented pictures in the newspaper
[Music]
no no don't do it don't do it no whoa
bad bad bad bad boys
is about to become the raid right now
oh geez no guys oh my gosh you guys are
how old are these are they teenagers
because they're acting like children
it man's people are the ones at fault
here as well yeah
and they're destroying other people's
art and work look what you're doing to
each other
they're all just itching to fight man
there's no winner
everyone's a loser it's like Alien
versus Predator
oh I'm so upset with you guys
wow oh man I'm devastated the further we
get into the story of it man the more
I'm afraid he's gonna snap it's supposed
snapping type no that's what I'm afraid
of
like where's the breaking what is he
gonna say to them right now like get it
together because you guys just destroyed
Something Beautiful
we've been here before
of course it is it says every person
with a clear conscience
oh my god dude
oh
wow
foreign
snack on some Pearls of Wisdom it man's
just the best bro he's like one of the
greatest protagonists of all time so
easy to root for him
oh
yeah
foreign
that's a bar
it's striving not to strive yeah don't
try too hard just kind of be here now
and flow be like water yeah
oh
all right what version are you of you
are you bringing to the table today sir
yeah
did you learn anything from the last few
times we've spoken
what I say Joy
enjoy
that's settled change in the tune so
he's inviting him to watch or
participate
he's just inviting to watch maybe he's
gonna show them kind of what they're up
against now
oh good that's good
ouch clearly you're fine enough the way
you are
um
will somebody get this yellow piece of
fat out of here you're making too much
noise
foreign
yeah it's good they got his back at
least I kind of like him too as the
perspective yeah return now you see what
he's up against the British dude socks
the fighter like someone's got to teach
that dude a lesson man someone needs to
deck that dude in the chops a racist
[__]
I knew it it's like they have very
different ideals in a way but a similar
kind of Integrity it's like the traitor
from last time uh
God what a weird game to have to play
now marketing and publicity it's not
pantomime Taylor this is Chinese boxing
do you know this actor I believe the
screaming gives them strength
well I mean you let out additional
energy when you oh my God oh my God oh
my God you hear him he said let's give
him something to scream about I hope
they kick his
yeah all those dudes should be able to
take this guy down kill him punch
nice
whoa
more power come on
I hate this I hate this I want to fast
forward
jolly good jolly oh
oh
what come on
no you should stick to dancing quinoa
[Music]
what's this
oh Jesus
[Applause]
oh no oh no some some real button it's
gonna happen oh no
no
yeah he gonna get hurt real bad enjoy
the show
and now he's probably gonna cry because
he got hit it man will destroy you [__]
yeah dude
[Music]
oh
buddy he's not gonna be the same like it
was all that you beat up on all their
students yeah
he wants you to apologize
what is this some stupid Chinese
tradition the winners have to apologize
to Losers
or if I had to do that I'd be
apologizing every day I hate this guy
hate him
he's a good actor though he's good at
this yeah and you beat me in a fight
yeah right now
and I'll apologize
I was gonna say how this is gonna go
with just all punches on his side he's
Gotta Lose right because IP man's gonna
have to come and beat him at some point
and so it's not gonna make sense yeah
he's probably gonna do some dirty he's
probably gonna cheat yeah something
really dirty he's gonna get hurt
who's in master hung's Corner IP get up
yeah foreign
because he's got the whole like
political array to figure out
he's gonna find out a way to beat this
guy without beating this guy yeah
oh my God
yeah get him on the ropes all right
come on man are you okay
oh boy I'm very worried
the fact that we met these characters
this movie
and we care this much
God the angles the camera movements are
so visceral too yeah
Master's out of breath yeah
oh no oh no oh boy
oh boy oh boy wow that was pretty Boss
No but the music is telling us otherwise
yeah
oh thank God for that thank God for the
Bell saved by the same literally Saved
by the Bell okay okay okay okay okay
okay
yep it's not just his though oh yeah
[Music]
I feel like you need a mouth guard or
something man
yeah he should manage to remind him of
his kids family family take their kids
to ice cream oh no no no no no no
oh no this is like Creed man I was gonna
say next movie they're gonna be fighting
Rocky no no ah
[Music]
no it don't die in the ring man
what are you saying he's gonna die I
think he might I'm I'm very afraid right
now
sorry to hit you really hard no it's all
good it's all good oh wow
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
no
come on
aha call the round like come on
let go of the ropes let go he's like not
letting go
ah
come on dude
it's barely in the room let go let go
let go oh no
no
oh
that is a dead master
oh no
go home boys
that's your new general that's the new
dude you gotta teach a lesson I
I hate him
that was actually really hard to watch
yeah that made me sick to my stomach I
am drained right now what's wrong with
people
you know how it Man's real person and
the first one's based off of that is
this one based off of anything it's a
good question I mean some of at least a
fair amount of this feels again
plausibly like it could be decently
based on history like is Master Hung a
person I wonder or maybe like some kind
of cheeky little nod to Samo hung or
like a relative perhaps
oh how far we came
how are you feeling right now bud yeah
like dog trash I'm sure
you've seen what the local newspapers
are saying about us the truth
you'd better take care of this I do not
want to be in the newspaper once more
for pulling the Chinese the Chinese what
accent was that all EDR like what was
that that was so weird yeah that was all
ADR I think the one guy was like kind of
German but not
foreign
wow
damaged short pants this is what happens
to people who mess with me ugh
hold his hands what
absolute worse stop
this is a war crime
what a Chinese boxer rather
overestimated himself
and challenged our champion
twister reluctantly accepted the
challenge
during the fight
unfortunately the Chinese boxer was so
weak they needed Tick-Tock during this
time podcast something yeah one camera
phone changed everything tragically died
oh my God
it's just like the most punchable to
protect my name and reputation
I've agreed
to fight any Chinese person let's go up
every Chinese person the Chinese like to
use these
and I would like to stick to that
tradition
I doubt that there is any Chinese fella
that has the guts to get in the ring
with me
this guy
this is crossed over into it it's a
hilarity like he's just I I hate him so
much doesn't never seen a villain as
villainous as that I don't wait to see
this guy taken down a peg
him
throwing down the gauntlet but IP is
gonna drive him nuts because he needs
that competitive element IP never beat
hung though right they yeah had like a
table split and then the kid was there
like he it's not like we know for sure I
mean I mean we know it dies in this one
yeah
no pressure they're right they know 100
he's got the whole country on his
background against like a Thanos Thanos
level villain I mean this guy sucks the
two British white dudes in this are just
the the least likable people I've ever
heard of in my life they're so ragey and
completely disrespectful in every
possible way
inspect your grit man oh no tight enough
said sedition huh
[Laughter]
really ability
oh I don't know if I trust that guy but
that's so beautiful he went back to
visit him after all he did for him what
an interesting like C storyline with the
guy with the duck yeah sorry I realized
that was a very vague chain of pronouns
just there but yes Quan is his name not
suspicious of him if deciding to look
after this guy who did so much for him
back in photon it's just a really lovely
detail oh no
oh no of course of course of course of
course is she gonna bring the baby to
the fight
yes yeah hold him up give them that
extra time
[Laughter]
and then you do the red stripe of his
forehead with the blood of Twister
[Music]
no she's a [__] Legend she is I mean
they are perfect for each other they are
the perfect team
suffering silently but with all the
Poise
when you want each other wins so bad uh
uh but it does feel rigged because we're
playing with boxing rules like the
rounds and the but they are allowing
kicks and stuff I'm a little yeah yeah
what are the rules here I'm surprised
they didn't Outlaw that
I love too that it takes no joy in any
of this
so many people
hate the British people they're just
like such a common villain and so many
people have been gallivanting throughout
history
colonizing yeah and oppressing stuff
right here yeah
people hate Americans too so you know
we've all done deplorable things in
times of War
[Music]
you can do it
I kind of want to see this guy in more
stuff yeah I wonder if he's like a like
you know a stunt actor like a an actual
fighter or something get to your corner
please
yeah that is so weird that he went to go
say hi
it's like they they're cartoonishly
disrespectful
it's on
ow is that the first thing we've seen
land on it
he's gotten a couple seems like whoa
it's okay he's taking him in he's
learning his style
oh
tireding him out
[Music]
oh oh
close Fists
foreign
cage
he's so sweet how you like that how's
that taste that was sick
twister you're not used to that honey
okay
oh
thank you
supposed to bring the Bell but he didn't
I guess I should brush up on my boxing
rules
get back to your corners
that guy's a cheater the bell ringer is
a cheater it's interesting I wonder what
his game is
come on buddy
let's pound him like raw meat
eyes dude you swallow your mouth guard
whoa
[Music]
whoa dude shot illegal hit it's a great
freeze with a flash bulb really quick
come on
cheater yeah you're bad sport Brad
please could you come
how can we figure out a way to make this
it man's fault
please tell the Chinese guy no more
kicks like these
no more kicks
I was waiting for it
we're moving the goal post is that clear
twister is my actual nemesis
oh man
wait wait wait wait one more kick you'll
be disqualified understand
muscle memory
careful
this has major Warrior Vibes sure you
okay
none of this is okay kicking is half of
his sport you can't take the kicking
away or you're it's it's illegal it's
you already agreed on yeah one Style
versus the other one all that implies
like otherwise you should take away the
other guy's gloves yeah Fair
come on buddy start wearing them down
let's go let's go destroy him
this is a really mean comic I hope he
dies
I wouldn't feel that bad
he brought it on himself he had every
opportunity
wow make him go yeah
the move
finish him
oh that nose is gonna be powder
what dude
two three
four five five everyone
seven eight nine ten
[__]
ah that is gratifying
that is cathart Dad won twice today [__]
newborn baby not as long as he doesn't
get shot like last time uh yeah let's
wait and see what happens here
step on him step all over him he had his
chance to be respectful
raise him up
[Music]
[Applause]
fabol has told me everything
your actions embarrassed the entire Hong
Kong police force
arrest him yes
throw him in the gulag wrong culture
about I don't care
mm-hmm
I
so you know oh
dude
[Applause]
out Sally good jolly good show if it
didn't mess up the shot I would stand I
know
oh you got yourself okay yeah go meet
your kid you don't even know your kid
was born yeah go decide on a baby name
oh
wow up on your feet and everything yeah
she's a legend she's a boss
see you later
[Music]
oh
walk that path of the righteous man
can babies just like be outside
that quickly I guess
oh people must have managed back then
yeah
it's a twister
it's his uncle oh
you actually
whoa hey
foreign huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was cool that's fun
little did he know
[Music]
oh wow
it's like I I learned Taekwondo back in
the day but like no I want to try out
some Wing Chun
it's like unbelievable
It's gotta take so long to master right
oh yeah
I mean because not only do you I like
this I like this rock and roll credits
music uh yeah it's like not only do you
have to I'm sure Master various
techniques and things like that but it's
also the repetition and building the
muscle memory and just you know kind of
aligning you know
your mind with as cliche as it sounds
aligned in your mind with your body so
that you can kind of move and flow
naturally from The Zone without having
to think too hard you know is this taut
here I'm sure it is I just don't I don't
know anybody who
what's the method called Wing Chun Wing
Chun I don't know anybody who took when
John or learned Wing John there are a
lot of different I mean just even around
here there are like a lot a lot a lot of
different martial arts schools I'm sure
there's one around it's like yeah
because you got Taekwondo which is
Korean and then yeah Taekwondo I know
people have taken you got karate you got
Kung Fu uh they're definitely there's
like a lot of jujitsu and stuff like
that and there's a lot of um all things
that like I regularly hear about but
there's people there are even places
that have like Jeet kundo which is the
Bruce Lee fighting style that he
developed
So based off of this
probably at least derived from sure yeah
probably mixing a few different schools
of thought I would imagine
but yeah there's gotta like I feel like
especially for as prolific as just the
figure of it man is plus these movies
and things like that like there's there
have to be Wing Chun schools around what
do you think of the second one versus
the first one
I mean this is really fun it's weird
like hearing
going in I was expecting something much
more Fantastical and something uh yeah
that just had more of that like
kind of Chinese Opera sort of style and
it definitely adds that but it's still
why are you expecting that you had heard
that or you just felt like yeah
I'd heard vaguely that the movies
progressively you know get a bit more
heightened and I think after the first
one being so surprised by just how
historical uh the basis was for the
story and and you know all the just all
the time and place elements I wasn't
expecting then coming out of that
I don't know I I
guess it's maybe a near-sighted
Assumption of like well that's the
historical story now we're kind of gonna
build out from Beyond that like this
still feels like it could easily be
based on history but I could also see uh
I think an easier potential for certain
events to maybe have been truncated or
um you know like fabricated like I would
be very curious to know if this was an
actual fight that took place if this was
an actual you know competition because
you know like the the British presence
in Hong Kong like again this isn't
history I know intimately well but yeah
like all the history lines up where I'm
like okay so we're still grounded there
and I guess in terms of colonization and
like who the villains were at the time
kind of stuff you mean yeah and just
like what the tensions are in culture
both uh you know just between the people
who were trying to make it by Under This
rule all the different you know Chinese
folks who are just trying to make their
livings and then
um you know how that further interacts
with you know the actual tyranny going
on or at least the actual colonization
occupation and how they are running
things and how they are sort of directly
influencing this like I like that you
see
um yeah it's like you meet Master Hung
and you see this sort of status quo of
this new environment that we're in and
how you know the different schools
interact with each other but then you
see like the great instead of basically
having this big shift into everybody now
being sort of plopped into this
nightmare situation of the Japanese
Occupation now it's like you're here you
find out one status quo only to be
introduced to the greater status quo
above all that which is you know the
Brits and what they are doing and how
they are treating everybody and the
greater concerns that go beyond just you
know our uh you know it's like him and
Master Hung there's so much of like
it's not just it's not as simple as just
you know fighting back in a certain way
it's like you kind of have to step
carefully around this situation and all
that stuff just kind of felt if not
built ripped from this guy's actual
history at least plausibly ripped from
history so yeah yeah I'm I'm with you I
I also think that but it what was really
working for me about this is that it's
about the the impression people have on
each other based on nothing based on
ignorance you know it's uh because when
we're talking about the historical
aspect of it
um it's also just about how British
people felt about people that they
deemed to be foreigners and what their
lack of respect of other cultures is and
watching this it's about being equals
and being respected equally in the the
lesson at the end about dignity and
about integrity
being it's it's not about proving you're
better than or that this school of
thought is better or that this school of
um fighting is better it's about being
respected and having different methods
that both work simultaneously and yeah I
thought that that was really cool
because I was beforehand I said to you
as we were coming in this movie I was
like I'm a little nervous because how
how is this gonna be as people say this
one's really good how is it gonna be
good compared to the first one which we
both loved but I thought the first one
the reason that I really loved it wasn't
just because it was a fighting movie it
was because of all the other stuff
surrounding it that really elevated it
and grounded it and so in this one I was
like okay so we know it's not going to
be about the Japanese Occupation so what
what can they do that makes me feel like
so much anger towards an enemy or a
villain and doesn't just make it like
inner fighting you know yeah it doesn't
come with that tragic element yeah and
fighting what they decided to do in this
one I was like oh right they just are
following the the timeline of uh of the
bullies and oh yeah bullies bullies
throughout history totally totally I
thought they did a really good job of
that but then at the end not being like
huh we were always better than you it's
ha we always deserve to exist yeah yeah
yeah and that universality of people's
dignity above all else and I think
that's you know it's such a cathartic
resolve because like this movie does
have I think a different sort of tonal
height especially with the British
characters like in the first movie The
Japanese
antagonists are much more
there's just a different Mystique in a
different kind of grounding that they
apply to those characters whereas here
and it is interesting because this is
you know like a Chinese production and
all that stuff and so like whenever like
yeah of course of course you're gonna
look at it like that yeah and whenever
like Brits or Americans show up in these
kinds of movies and even speaking
English there's just like a different
kind of Timbre to how the performances
go but I think just in the tone
generally they had much more
without it working against the movie
like it's not complaint but there was
like a a greater height a more
over-the-top quality to the antagonists
here that does kind of elevate the
fantasy level a bit you know it does
have like more of a clear-cut sort of
enemy situation just because twister and
his like main Handler guy uh with the
British army is they're just so pompous
and so disrespectful all the time
and uh you just cannot wait to see them
have their asses handed to them and I
think they do nicely to make them
formidable like twister is for me at
first I was like what are you gonna do
you're a boxer these people like no
kicks and and various like combinations
of things and not to slight boxing it is
just a different
school of thought and style of fight but
yeah it's a different sport it's a
different sport with different rules and
I feel like you know if you're applying
that I was surprised it took them so
long to be like hey we got to take these
kicks out of here I'm like he's not even
wearing gloves like this is you know
which I get the point is to be like
we're gonna prove that our method even
with all the advantages given to you is
better
um but yeah it does it does make me kind
of curious to learn more like these both
make you want to go and and you know
kind of uh immerse yourself in some kind
of martial art but it also made me
curious to kind of learn better the just
sort of lexicon of boxing and how that
works definitely very true the this
movie the main fighter twister he is not
the villain as much even though you hate
him it's really the other guy that
bothers me so much the British dude
skinny short pants yeah short pants dude
because the thing about twister is that
Fighters today 2023 in this country a
lot of them are [__] they want to
fight not all of them but like a lot of
people well there's an element of the
show of the show and the sh and the crap
talking and the you know like I'm gonna
beat you know it happens to this day
where people get injured in when you
sign up to fight somebody you know like
there's some serious injuries that take
place so as much as I'm like oh my God
you're the worst you suck because you
have a judgment judgment our entire
culture that's false and you're ignorant
it's like as opposed to the last one the
main villain was also the fighter you
know this one the British dudes short
pants he's not a fighter he has just
like it's so annoying to watch him
because you can't even like if anybody
threw one punch at you you would be out
you would be destroyed but in the last
one at least the guy at the top was like
the one who gets in the ring at the end
and you're like you have to have some
respect for that the reason this one
tall short pants dude was so annoying is
because it's just like all of us sitting
at home when we watch fights being like
punch him order play faster and it's
like bro you would be out in two seconds
yeah you hide behind your status and
your and your station and you think that
you're the king of the world just
because of that and you come in and you
hit somebody's hand with a stick yeah
you have no skill yeah you gotta have
the second guy held down and it's just
for yeah hold them tighter what because
you because you would be screwed if
there weren't five people holding him
yeah because you have no ability and if
you didn't have your political leverage
here which I thought they made some
interesting stuff out of because I
didn't know where to go they just kept
calling the character fat so I don't
remember his actual name I feel bad
calling him that but like no I wasn't
sure where to lean with him and I liked
that ultimately it seemed like he was
sort of he he was true to his word he's
like no print the truth and I'm gonna go
tell him that this I'm gonna go tell you
know I don't know the MPS or whoever
that this guy is severely out of line
and is not you know is
you know there's that thing of of course
they have the upper hand and there is an
oppression Happening Here of some
variety and there are deals being made
and all that stuff but you know it's
like the guy is asking to be you know to
at least taken down from his station and
and you know tried for all kinds of
misconduct yeah and so I wasn't
expecting that but I was like oh cool
well at least you know they're gonna
show up and maybe I don't know reprimand
this dude a little better or again at
least yeah remove strip him of his ranks
and all that stuff it's like you want to
see that guy get get the [__] beat out
of him but definitely yeah but it's it
is still this is him getting the ship
beat out of him in his world in his yeah
you're losing your power yeah and like
without your power you legitimate change
nothing I think that uh I'm we were like
joking around for a second about if one
camera phone just a podcast whatever it
is but it is crazy that today you know
we always talk about people say like
there's so much more oppression there's
so much more and it's like this is just
in history we just don't have the camera
phones to show what pieces of crap
everybody was still wore yeah and that's
that I love that little Motif they bring
in of like he the
um oh God what's his name the the
um the guy from the Mill's son who gets
the job of the paper and uh he's doing
the pictures the one who calls him Uncle
man or yeah Uncle man and uh yeah he's
like putting pictures in and you realize
like yeah all they had to go off of like
a radio broadcast and you know the
newspaper and those things can easily
you watch I think in one in that press
conference as they spin the fight with
Master Hung about being like you know uh
he reluctantly said yes yeah you know
twister was like I guess you know and
you know he only threw a couple punches
and I guess this guy just he just really
overestimated his ability and twister
did everything he could to hold back and
uh then this guy died and you know Mr
gets on the mic and Twister's like oh
and then you're stupid incense and
whatever and I'm like you are the worst
you've been punching ahead one too many
times my dude
and like that's the thing is it's an
interesting it's an interesting quality
that they get you to a point where you
are I don't know like the philosophy of
Ip is is such that you wouldn't root for
someone to really get beat up in any
situation but they're good at bringing
you to this point where you're like nah
these dudes are bad dudes and even IP
realizes like I have to teach these guys
a lesson and I also have to lead with my
example you know I have to show
everybody around me that you know we
cannot give in like it kind of
complements all that stuff at the
beginning because there are things about
this movie that are kind of similar
structurally to the first one you start
out with just a bunch of sort of clashes
between different schools of martial
arts that also apply to again the
hierarchy of
uh you know it's like hung seems like
he's put in this position to be an
intermediary between the people who are
really running the show and then he can
kind of run things on a day-to-day basis
and so yeah you go from all these
squabbles that feel like they exist on
that level that then ultimately Crest
into this bigger thing where it's like
you're being pulled into some
competition that the odds are stacked
way against you because it's all
controlled by these Invaders and stuff
like that yeah the infighting is so
stupid because it's really it's not each
other you're mad at you're mad at the
circumstances that none of you have
money none of you have the food or
shelter that you need yeah the other
similarity between this one and the
first one there is a bunch but in the
first one and in this one it kind of
took me a minute to know what story we
were gonna tell like it's not like you
know a typical three-act structure which
we see in a lot of Cinema where there's
then the inciting incident at 10 minutes
in and then we break for act one act two
you know it takes us kind of like until
maybe 45 of minutes into these like that
midpoint or or a little before that Mark
to be like oh this is what we're doing
because at first you think that this is
going to be between Master hung's
students and Ip Man students you know
they kind of point it that way and it
takes a long time to get to actually the
enemy of your enemy is your friend
and if we could all just kind of we
there's more of us than there are them
and when you do join forces and merge
then you're more powerful and it and in
both this movie and in the first one it
does it takes its time it really
breathes at the beginning I think that
one of the reason I'm liking this so
much is that the structure is so
different than what we typically see in
American Cinema which tells you
immediately this is what this movie is
about now you know this is what the
movie's about and this is kind of like
wait for it well yeah it looks like we
gotta hop in you know first five ten
minutes we've got to know exactly what's
going on and like I I yeah I really like
the grad visual build and and the way
that again both movies sort of allow you
the first one has a much more harsh like
nope that the occupation has now
happened and everything is about to
change the colors have changed the flags
have changed yeah locate everything
yeah everything's changed yeah whereas
here it's this yeah slow build up and
you catch you know if and his family in
a more working person's position you
know okay we're in this new place we
gotta start up a school we got to find a
way to make money we're struggling a
little bit okay here are this these
little you know again Petty squabbles
and the little difficulty like I love
just the build of you have it first you
know this guy who comes in who's like
yeah I'll see about paying your fees uh
you know if you could defeat me and you
start on just this yeah this just little
whippersnapper who becomes his first
student and then his little Crohn's who
then become the next batch of students
and then you have the schools fighting
and then you escalate into an in like an
unfolding situation it's not so much
that there's like a harsh tone shift
it's not like oh snap now the bridge
have arrived it's just oh you didn't
realize what this the shape of the
Fishbowl you're in is you didn't realize
how many layers there are and so I think
that creates a nice sort of gradual
Dynamic to where yeah things start out
really on the ground level and feeling
very intimate and and just sort of day
by day and then you slowly Crest into
this like huge sort of problem of
principle
by the end it would be obviously I know
that this was they say 1950 something
but it it would be cool to see some of
the women fight a little bit I know I
was gonna say what are we are we
pre-time where that was like an
acceptable thing for for women to do I
know when we in the first one obviously
when everybody's training everybody
starts to train in the uh the factory
and stuff remember whatever so they you
know no people left out but it you know
I would like to see his wife pull a
couple
punches and do or do a couple things
it'd be cool if some of the kids signing
up when they're teens or whatever oh
dude I know people are gonna rip on me
for that I'm sorry that I want women to
be able to fight too I'm so sorry guys
well they did it in the first book I
mean it wasn't like a big focal thing
but they at least trained all the people
at the Mill and some of them were women
and some of them were shown on screen
throwing down so that's what I'm saying
like you know in the third one maybe one
of the students maybe just one yeah yeah
it seems like you could like to be a
woman practicing martial arts at this
point in time either things have to be
so desperate that everyone's doing it or
maybe you're just that special but but
yeah like I am maybe a little bit
surprised by that and it seems like the
further we get into this just historical
timeline the more it seems like
everybody should know how to defend
themselves a little bit just because you
never know who you're going to be up
against both like home and from abroad
that's what I'm saying I think it's an
easy way in the third one like to train
your wife you know you want her to be
able to ask your kids when you're not
home and it'll be nice to see she could
handle it I can't imagine her fighting
because she's just so she's crazy
so but then again she's got all these
qualities where I'm like that would
probably eat in your fighting ability to
make you very graceful and light on your
feet oh I feel I feel you guys are
already hating on me for it I'm sorry
it's one note it's a little note I love
the movie at the time you know I'm sure
that and and two I mean I don't know and
bringing that up I'm sure that there is
history as to like when it became more
prominent and acceptable for women to
join in this kind of you know study in
school of thought and uh and hey maybe
there's some of that to come who knows I
really have no idea what do you think
about the third one is there anything
that you would really want to see or is
there anything that you would expect
I have so so curious do you want to go
to the Bruce Lee route like we just met
little Bruce Lee
I know and and in the part I just
freaking Netflix man like I feel like
you should know on movies like this
where it's like the I had to go back and
and Rewind The the little uh captions at
the very end because it said he finally
took Bruce Lee they show you like a
bunch of [__] you're supposed to watch
next and I'm like there are subtitles
yeah
it's so annoying uh but apparently he
took on Bruce Lee in 1956 as it says
here and so we meet him when he's like a
child here so yeah we we must be on like
the cusp of the 50s here like just just
before just around and so yeah like it
man three I guess I would expect it has
to be
approaching the 50s or 60s or something
so I would I would imagine a Bruce Lee
presence of of some kind I almost don't
expect him to be like a main character
but maybe I mean you know that's a fun
little kid messing around starting to
learn yeah like a teenager just sort of
part of The Ensemble but maybe not and
maybe even like with a bit of
spotlighting but not yeah like the main
supporting character necessarily
um I don't know I mean and then villain
wise are you expecting them again to go
this route where like it you know at
first it is Japanese people then it is
the Brits she wants them to stay in that
British hemisphere
that's not the right word in that
angular realm yeah thematic realm I
don't know
I I do like and and this one the first
movie is much more of like this is a
historical drama and also you know very
much a martial arts movie with creative
Liberties for sure sure this one is a
bit more martial arts movie certainly
still historical drama but a bit more
steeped in and focused on you know these
various fights and and things like that
I feel like there's just a little bit
more Scene stuff between the fights in
the first movie which is not a complaint
um I guess I would expect in the third
movie to be still pretty fight heavy I
have to imagine though that there's
you know they're always testing IPS
Poise and pushing him to a point where
he has to fight in order to inspire
people and while on the one hand I'm
like well it would be cool to try a
different Dynamic I do think that is
kind of a Cornerstone because of his
personality it's like he's got to get to
that point where he's like I have to do
this not for myself not for the fight
not for a show but because this is for
everybody like I'm fighting on behalf of
a principle for everybody so I feel like
that kind of needs to stay intact but
I'm also like I don't know what what we
could do in history that's gonna force
that to happen so yeah I have no idea I
can almost expect maybe some kind of
left turn or maybe some kind of America
presence in the next one I don't know
people like the third one
people love the third one also right
yeah the only people seem very chuffed
on the entire series I've heard more
mixed things about part four but at
least the first three people seem to
love kind of unanimously so either way
I'm excited no matter what but I yeah I
kind of of him like each I think it's
good I think it's a sign that you you
really you know put it all out there
when you get to the end of one of these
movies and you're like or what we're
gonna do next man totally aside for
maybe just like IPS still trying to run
that school yeah he left it all out on
the floor some bullshit's about to sweep
in and he's gonna have to take up the
mantle and you know well maybe we have a
school for him you know they took away
this school so maybe there's a more
established school yeah maybe in the
third one he's finally able to have like
a few locations it's a franchise
franchise man totally I hope that that
one main guy that first came to fight
him that then became his number one
pupil
stays in the third one
from this one yeah the guy who shows up
at the top yeah I do too they said
there's one like throwaway line word
there like he's okay he's resilient so
I'm sure he could come back and I would
like that too like I think it would be
like I like the way that this movie in
not a huge in your face way but you they
brought back gin and they brought back
uh his buddy from the factory with the
duck and that was really tragic
um that was I felt really bad for him
well there's ramifications of War time
you know and I think they were showing
that and
um this guy I liked and want to see him
move forward because especially that one
conversation they have when they're
sitting there and he comes to apologize
to him like I took your school away from
you and I felt like that showed humility
in a way that a lot of young people
don't have and realizing yeah that under
he clearly is starting to understand the
message that it's not just about like
you know proving yourself or fighting
for your own reputation here in the
moment there's much more you can't be
goaded by people and you have to rise
above that and that's principle that
your Martial Arts should inhabit and you
can see him really taking that to heart
in a moment like that which I think is
really lovely because you know so many
of these guys are just itching to throw
down yeah totally the second they walk
in they're like let's fight it's like
you gotta burn that my dude yeah it's
like our school's the best and you know
it's I do appreciate that that so many
people show up all cocky and then all
you got to do is is like really you know
whoop them a little bit and they're like
teach me yeah on their knees I'm
completely open to your training and
philosophy now yeah I'm with you yeah
I don't know like it's it's just I love
you know I have to imagine that this is
somewhat based on the real guy's
personality I just love the personality
of he is such a great centerpiece
because there's so many characters in
such big situations and in a lot of ways
it's not just like that's the cool part
about the historical aspect is it does
feel like a broader thing about a lot of
people but it just so happens that he is
at the core kind of anchoring the grace
of it all yeah definitely I mean I I
think I said like 15 times throughout I
love Ip Man like that's it it's a good
thing that I love the character because
the whole movie is really contingent on
you really liking him and he inspires
like it's an inspiring character like
you you want to take that level of poise
with you wherever you go in that level
of Grace yeah I was kind of thinking
about that as we were watching too the
way that he says every time he wins the
fight like thank you for letting me win
yeah I was like um I think we could all
use a little more of that you know
instead of rubbing things in people's
faces or even like congratulating
yourself just immediately trying to make
somebody else feel better about their
loss yeah because because yeah it's it's
not about a fight for him even it's like
it's just a demonstration it's just the
chance of this particular fight because
he knows he's the best
I guess so it's weird it's like I don't
even think he's thinking about it I
don't think he's no I don't mean it like
that I just you know when I say he knows
he's the best as in like he's got
nothing left to prove to himself yeah
he's just like I I don't have to impress
you and say like I won because it we
ever it is what it is you just saw so
I'm secure in my ability I don't have to
prove anything and yeah like even if I
did happen to lose it wouldn't be the
end of the world I will lose so I like
that too that whole thing about like hey
in 20 years you'll be able to beat me no
one's the best forever you know yeah he
just seems like a very Zen guy yeah yeah
grounded is a good word for it you know
not too much in and also yeah like it
reminded me of that line he says in the
first movie to to one of the pupils
about like you know you can't be just
all up in your head about technique you
know and I think that's another big
thing that these kind of hone you in on
is like I loved when they outlawed the
kicks and he throws one out and you're
like oh yeah yeah you're probably so
used in it yeah those reflexes and it's
part of what makes you so good but now
that's a that's a handicap because
you've got to factor all that out and
you've got to now be thinking harder in
the moment and that's a great little way
to drive up that that tension and yeah
it's like even though there are Beats
that are similar they all feel very
natural and they don't feel like
rehashed or derivative or anything like
that yeah he's Ip Man he's very quick
he's quick man whip man oh I'm gonna say
you know as much as he doesn't seem like
the kind uh you know to be a ball buster
I bet he's got some quips I bet he's got
some quests every now and again he'll
sneak one by you that you're like ah
like I didn't even catch it at first but
ah you got me
yeah it's like I said we can't watch him
and Master Hung like be Pals now because
it seemed like there could have been
like a really fun friendship I am bummed
that he died and can't be in the next
one maybe we'll get some Throwbacks to
him but that that is it that's it was
awful and the funeral was like such a
different looking setting from
everything else it's a really good job
of that minus
the hood the pointy the whole pointy
hoods are historically uh unfortunately
problematic uh given what's yeah they're
given what we will soon do with them in
history or may have been already
probably doing in history with them
um but it was yeah very striking to be
like oh we're in a space that is just
like all white and and and and
everything is very
like peaceful or well it's that mournful
Serenity but also everything is like a
little bit more pristine than everything
else you know because you want
everything to be you know as as nice as
it can be and you're in a place that is
sort of impoverished nobody has money
not not everything is like you know kept
in ship-shaped cleanliness or whatever
so it is like a very there's like a
sterility that comes with the
mournfulness there
um but two just huge props to Sam oh
hung and I'm not like the biggest expert
I've seen a few of his uh films of
Jackie Chan most notably and maybe a
couple others that Center on him but
he's just I mean he's prolific in
Martial Arts Cinema and Chinese Opera
and stuff like that and I thought he was
Opera yeah yeah which which not not uh
not the same idea as like you know a
operatic song I don't know anything
about Chinese Opera um again I'm not
like a huge expert but I I have you know
did a little bit of reading in that
Jackie Chan biography and they came up
together and yeah just to see him I mean
he's such a prolific again martial
artist and you know martial arts movie
presence both in front of him behind the
camera so you know you have Donnie Yen
who's already such a terrific actor and
martial art and then that's you know
like a real lucky thing going from this
these movies to like John Wick chapter
four it's like Donnie and obviously he's
got the presents and the moves but he's
like a great actor too yeah he's really
good and a table scene man that was like
again and yes like such like the concept
of that is so great because yeah it's
like you gotta focus on the fight but
you also got to focus on your
surroundings because you're going to be
tilting and whirling and the way they
shot that too like that's another part
of this movie that seemed like it got a
bit more Juiced up is uh
they cut they was there were more cuts
and there were more sort of crazy angles
and camera movements a lot of like
interesting little like zooms or whips
and things and not in in like a really
good way I thought like you know
especially in American action you can
see things that are just edited to hell
and it's just like throw every camera
angle at it and people will get the idea
whereas here I think it takes
it's like you have the fight
choreography which is already impressive
and mind-blowing on its own but I
thought they stepped up even further on
the camera choreography to accentuate
the fight choreography
um and yeah like
superbly exemplified in that uh table
fight with all the little chairs and and
the subtle use of of I would imagine
wires for certain stuff you know going
into that you know slightly more
Fantastical style but but keeping it
very grounded in the in the use of those
even still you're not like full-on
Crouching Tiger crying but you know
there is a little bit more of that
lightness of air in there
definitely the the movie does a really
good job of telling of showing us how to
feel based on everything other than the
script the script also does that but
like with the colors and with the the
music which like especially in the fight
scenes you can hear in the music oh oh
something's coming you know and like you
know how to feel and it's kind of
um training your mind when you're seeing
the different colors and some things are
lighter than others and some have a
little more pop to them and
um all of that it's letting you know
what's coming not in like a spoiler way
but just uh this is bad this is good
this is what this looks like they really
thought about all the elements and then
we talked a little bit about the use of
props but I just felt like the props in
this movie really elevated the fights
from and differentiated the fights from
the first movie because in the first
movie we had these incredible fights and
then yes in the factory with the
feathers and all of the things that went
down but in this one the the usage of
that wooden board right or of all the
knives
yeah there was just so many different
elements that made it like imagine being
on set rehearsing for this movie you
know imagine those fight scenes like how
are you doing that like how do you do
that there's so many moving parts and
everybody's got their own thing and some
of the shots we're seeing dozens of
people do the their thing at once and
you're working with tools and props that
like you really can't f up
and they're all so trained in a way
that's like
I mean it's the coolest dance you've
ever seen in your life just the way that
they have to do all that as somebody who
has been on sets before I can't imagine
the pressure every single person is
under and also just like how you do that
just seems like it would take a million
hours
yeah and from what little I know again
about how they do it in in Chinese and
Hong Kong Cinema is is yeah it's like
you have this intense level of
choreography but I think you also have
on the FL it's like here in our action
movies there's lots of Regulation and
there's lots of you know making sure
that everything is like super duper safe
whereas from my understanding more kind
of you know from from my understanding
in these movies there's more sort of
like let's figure it out on the day and
let's you know kind of throw stuff at
the wall and see what works and kind of
there's a maybe a little more
spontaneity and also just a little bit
more acceptance that like yeah you're
gonna get hit a little bit you know
we're gonna do some of these things
pretty fast and we're gonna do some of
these things in ways that maybe aren't
the most safe but it seems like
everybody is game for I think it's just
a different sensibility like on the one
hand I'm like yeah like so many things
could go wrong and and here in America
you're like how many ways can you get
sued but yeah I mean throughout again
watching hearing accounts of different
crazy stunts and stuff like that a lot
of of it is like kind of held together
on a shoestring and it is just about you
know a group of people kind of working
it out on the day and finding the
coolest thing that they're all willing
to throw down for right the freestyle of
it all is probably why it looks so good
but sure it does sound a little
dangerous to me but also if this is your
craft and that's how you want to deal
with it you are right like this with the
who's gonna get sued that mentality
definitely uh prevents art from being
the best that it can be sometimes yeah
it's like I'm sure coming like crossing
over I'm sure it's probably a lot more
fuss to do an American action movie than
like a Chinese action movie for a lot of
these types of actors who are you know
heavy into stunt work and martial arts
like you think Donnie Yen for John Luke
was like oh this is how it's done all
right I mean he knows well enough about
it see the thing is watching a John Wick
movie part of Migos okay I feel like
these guys probably are steeped in this
kind of Cinema too and that kind of
tradition so if ever a Hollywood set was
probably more willing to be like ah you
know we're kind of all stunt people and
even the like actor actors who are here
most all have gone through some level of
training so we can probably play a
little more loose with those lines but
yeah I mean in general I think it would
be a bit more restrictive crossing over
to here it's like you watch something
like John Wick four and you're like I
don't think Donnie Yen was restricted in
any way totally he was asked about his
character for them I think he said they
were like did you base it off of and he
said I just wanted to be as badass as
humanly possible or something yeah
mission accomplished man that he the
thing about him being so charismatic is
he can blink and I'm like intrigued sure
but even when he was looking so much
Presence at master
um hung and they they're looking at each
other and and
um he you can tell he doesn't want
Master Hung to keep fighting because
he's about to die but their eye contact
with each other was just disturbingly
upsetting you know just you're watching
and it's like desperate because what it
man knows is that he's not wrong and
he's fully understanding what this guy's
real position is like I thought their
their Arc of understanding each other
was really beautifully handled and and
props I started saying earlier to Samo
hung because I mean he has just as much
you know poison presence even though
he's presented as more of an antagonist
from the start like again his martial
arts abilities and his presence as a
character you know like when he goes
down you really feel for that and part
of that is a circumstance but a huge
amount of that is just him and the way
that yeah I think that that that moment
of realization in him being like it's
not that easy you know like I I can't
just take him down you know the in this
a I mean you know he's clearly
formidable but be there's just so much
more here than either of us really kind
of can fully grasp I wonder if his kids
will be a part of the third one you know
he left behind a wife a whole family I
could totally see it what happens with
them does Master IP take care of them I
can see it and I mean they they've I
think that was one of the nice things
about this is that sort of it makes the
world feel alive even though you're not
focusing on most of the characters from
the last movie in you know great depth
they are still here and they all have
lived and they serve a little purpose
especially Jin showing like yeah you can
grow Beyond being this this hot head guy
so yeah like in a story like this that
sort of
um you know just the sorrow and the and
the uh just the I don't know the
crushing blow of having your father
taken from you in such a harsh Manner
and your husband you know take it from
you in such a harsh manner I could
definitely see those characters
factoring back in I just don't know what
direction they would have to go in yeah
it might be small moments or whatever
but yeah things for more human dramatic
quality rather than like oh we gotta go
on some Revenge Mission or something
like that yeah building continuing yeah
just as like a One-Stop storyline kind
of like the guy with the duck where it's
like you know we see him like three
times maybe but he's got his own arc
yeah and it's just a little thing but
even that him him realizing at the end
and sort of some of that memory coming
back and even he has sort of healed a
little bit through this it's like such a
beautiful little they didn't have to do
that at all you know and I thought that
was a nice again really compassionate
little story and a great way to show
constantly if it's just trying to do
like the the truly good altruistic thing
for people even when nobody's watching
even
you know it's not like he at this point
has his riches he gives the money for
the duck even though he can't pay his
own rent yeah yeah it's just like his
use this who we should all aspire to be
and and in the most important moments is
when nobody's looking you know like
that's when it's true truest
so uh not performative just doing it
yeah yeah yeah it's like he runs the
Spectrum and it's like and then when it
gets to be in front of everybody it's
not even about that you know it's not
for that and it's clear and his little
speech at the end
simple brief but incredibly
straightforward and super poignant yeah
he says like that that's all
right that's all yeah I'm not here to
talk [__] I just hope that maybe we can
all you know be a little bit more
tolerant of each other and recognize
that all people have dignity thanks you
know and and yeah I think that's really
lovely wonderful message and yeah like
especially looking at modern times there
is that tradition of [__] talking and
whatnot and hey it's part of the
pageantry it's part of the fun but you
know there is a line and I think they
just do a great job here showing people
who just have absolutely no respect I
mean well part of it was just straight
up racism I mean they were calling and
stuff too that's like we're so far past
the line I can't even see the line
anymore yeah
yeah
well golly we did it golly gee this this
certainly had nothing to say about this
movie yeah we're just such Ip Man fans
now it's cool to be part of the Ip Man
Fan Club
having it man one live up to the hype it
man two live up to the heights I feel
like this might be an Ip Man 3 Journey
that we're on we'll see it's coming yeah
I think the real one the real question
mark for me
because sometimes also three is a nice
sweet spot you know you what are you
Indiana jonesing right now that's right
because then we're gonna have to get it
man five to fix whatever went wrong in
about four and then then you're you know
in a whole other perilous game once I'm
on a journey though I'm on the journey
and I'm signed up I'm signed up I'm here
for Ip Man 15 if that's what it takes
yeah and I mean even if it meant for
whatever other installment isn't you
know as great as the first I'll always
be happy to check in with the guy you
know yeah totally I'll be happy to check
I'm sure there are elements that are
still great yeah well all right thank
you for for enduring for braving the
challenge with me and thank you guys as
well for your enthusiasm Your Love down
in the comments we have had an absolute
blast and a half covering these and I
personally would absolutely adore the
opportunity to do the next one so if you
want that comment below leave a like on
the video that helps us out immensely uh
go on over to patreon if you want to see
The Full Experience shopzeroedition.com
if you want some reject swag to support
the channel that way and look good in
the process and uh hey we'll catch you
on the next one much love people be good
be it man be it man
[Music]